the mouth of the Columbia River known as
the graveyard of the Pacific it was a
Mayday call over the radio this boat its
next victim at that time various Coast
Guard assets were put into motion
including students from the Coast
Guard's Advanced helicopter rescue
school who were training nearby
conditions on scene were approximately
20 foot seas and extremely heavy winds
at about 10 40 a.m a trainee jumped into
the water swimming to the boat seconds
before it capsized he was brought back
to air station Astoria and uh he was
mildly hypothermic and you know suffered
some minor injuries back on Shore the
man was taken to hospital and the rescue
swimmer no longer just a trainee and
actually within a few hours of coming
back on Shore graduated from the school
so it's a heck of a graduation day and a
heck of a first rescue to kick off his
career and the Mariner was released from
hospital but that's when things took a
turn we put together two and two that it
was the same guy and we have since
learned that he stole a boat from the
port of Astoria but there's more only a
couple days earlier another incident
involving the same man and a local
landmark in town a home that starred in
a popular movie it went up to The
Goonies house covered the cameras with
stickers put a fish on the porch and
then was dancing around the property and
it doesn't end there Jericho labont is
wanted on BC wide warrants Victoria
Police putting out this poster only two
weeks ago the charges against him
criminal harassment mischief and three
counts of failure to comply the charges
are adding up the longer he's out and
unfortunately the hospital he was
released from the hospital before we
connected the dots and realized that it
was the same person but the story
finally reached a conclusion late Friday
night labont was arrested ending a
bizarre series of events that even this
veteran police chief no I cannot say
that I has never seen before jasimbala
Global News